انطلقت في الخرطوم اعماله مؤتمر تفكيك
نظام البشير وتعد هذه القضيه احدى قضايا
خمس تشملها العمليه السياسيه نهائيا التي
تستند الى الاتفاق الايطالي في مسحها
لتشكيل حكومه مدنيه دون اي تدخل من الجيش
وفي ظل دعم دولي الواسع يبقى توسيع دائره
التوافق بين القوه السياسيه حول برود
الاتفاق التحدي الاكبر بمسار التسويه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مساره ما الذي تقوله اولى
المؤشرات بشان قدره المرحله النهائيه
للعمليه السياسيه في السودان على تحديد
وتنفيذ خرائط طريق بشان قضايا دور الجيش
وشكل الحكومه الانتقاليه ومسار الانتخابات
ثم ما مدى حدود تلك العمليه في الايفاء
بوعودها بالنظر الى رفضها من قبل بعض
مكونات في الشارع السوداني وتطلع
السودانيين الى تغيير المباشر وملموس في
ظروفهم المعيشيه ثم نتساءل عن ما بوسع
المجتمع الدولي تقديمه للخروج في البلاد
من ازماتها هذا الترحيب الواسع ببلوغ قطار
التسويه محطاته النهائيه
[موسيقى]
هو واحد من المؤتمرات التي يفترض بها ان
تعالج القضايا الخمس المطروحه على العمليه
السياسيه النهائيه وهي في طريقها نحو
اتفاق النهائي يطوي الازمه السودانيه
بتاسيس حكومه مدنيه بعيدا عن اي تدخل من
الجيش ومع انتهاء اعمال هذا المؤتمر الى
اصدار مقررات من المنتظر ان تنطلق مؤتمرات
وورش عمل اخرى تبحث قضايا العداله
والعداله الانتقاليه واصلاح مؤسستين الامن
والجيش واتفاق السلام وقضيه شرق السودان
مسار سرعان دولي وسط دعوات لتوسيع دائره
التوافق حوله صدرت عن الامم المتحده
وغيرها من الهيئه
في هذه هي الاثناء تطرح اطراف سياسيه
مواقف رافضه للاتفاق بدرجات متفاوته من
بين اهمها تعرف بتنسيقيات لجان المقاومه
والحزب الشيوعي فضلا عن الكتله
الديمقراطيه التي قالت قيادتها انه اذا
استمر الطرف الاخر في المضي قدما ستكون
خيارات الكتله مفتوحه بينها تحريك قواعدها
الشعبيه لاسقاط الاتفاق الايطالي حسب
قولها
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم كل من
الدكتور صديق تاور عضو مجلس القياده
السوداني السابق وكذلك معنا كمال اسماعيل
رئيس حزب التحالف السوداني والقيادي بقوه
الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي واللواء
محمد عجيب مدير الاعلام العسكري السابق
اهلا بضيوف الكرام العلي ابدا بضيف السيد
كمال اسماعيل اقرا معه المؤشرات حتى الان
فيما يتعلق بان تكون هذه المحطه محطه
مؤسسه
لواقع يتمناه السودانيون هو الدخول في
عمليه سياسيه حقيقيه تهدئ الشارع
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
تحيه لكل مشاهدي قناه الجزيره
الاخباريه في البدء اترحم على كل شهداء
الثوره السودانيه منذ قيام انقلاب البشير
المشؤوم والى
الان
اولا
نحن سودانيين
لدينا خبرات كثيره ومقاومه كبيره لكل
الانظمه الديكتاتوريه المراد على بلادنا
تستطيعين ان نسقتها بوحدتنا
وحده القوه المدنيه واخيرا انحياز القوات
المسلحه
للشعب السوداني
الايطالي هو عباره عن مفتاح
ووضع على اساس انه
كل القوه
التي التي لديها اي ملاحظات تقدمه
فيلم بدا على هذا الاساس
واعتمد تماما انه هو مخرج
لنا جميعا لاستعاده الديمقراطيه واستعاده
الحريات
والمضيء قدما في سلام بلدنا مدير
المحطه كقراءه في مؤشرات حتى الان وهنا
اسال ضيف ايضا من قرطوم الدكتور صديق تاور
فيما يتعلق بما اذا كان هذا الاطراف يجمع
عدد لا باس به من الاطراف داخل السودان
تحت ام ظل دوليه واقليميه وبالتالي ما
الذي يمنع ان ينجح في ارسال دعائم مرحله
انتقاليه حقيقيه لما بعدها
ايه يا عم شكرا جزيلا على اهلا وسهلا
المستمعين وساده المشاهدين والمشاهدات
على قناه الجزيره الاخباريه
اعتقد
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي كان عناوين يبدو
للناظر بشكل سريع بانه يتضمن اشياء جيده
يمكن ان تحقق بعض المطلوبات وكذا ولكن اذا
نظرنا همم عين همم
هناك اشكالات كبيره همم تعترض هذا الاتفاق
ال ال الايطالي همم تجعل يعني بعيد عن
تحقيق مطلوبات الثوره السودانيه الباحثه
عن سلطه مدنيه همم حقيقيه بمعنى ادقه من
الاجابه على ما تفضلت به من همم من سؤال
اه اولا هذا الاتفاق
الايطالي لم يسمي الاشياء باسمائها في ما
يتعلق
السلطه المدنيه الحقيقيه
انقلاب 25 اكتوبر والتجريمه في معركه
الانتقال الديمقراطي الامر الثاني اعتبار
المكون الانقلابي الذي انقلب على السلطه
المدنيه
مسيرته بكل اعتباره طرف اساسي في رسم
خريطه
للانتقال همم وجوزهم من ترتيبات الفتره
الانتقاليه وهو خارج السلطه خارج السلطه
السلطه المدنيه او الحكومه المدنيه التي
ينبغي ان تنبثق عن هذا الاتفاق ثالثا انه
هذا الاتفاق تم بمعزل عن القوه
الحقيقيه قوه الثوره السودانيه الحريه
والتغيير 2022 ليست هي الحريه والتغيير في
2019 التي كانت هي المظله الرئيسيه ولكن
باعتراف باعتراف
او المكون العسكر ومطرحته من اشكالات لم
يتعلق كما ذكر الدكتور صديق بمن وصفهم
بالانقلابيين ما تعليقات
اتفق في انهو هنالك وجود اشكالات كبيره
وتحديات تواجه الاتفاق الايطالي
وليس ما تفضل به دكتور تاور وحده ولكن اهم
من ذلك ان هذا الاتفاق تم في ارضيه مشتركه
تحركت اليها اضرار هي بعد ان دخلت قوى
الحريه والتغيير الميس
المركزيه الثلاث الشهيره
وتخلل العسكريون ايضا عن تسريح عن تصريحات
السابقه بان لم تتمنى لك التسويه همم
ثنائيه بين الطرف من اطراف العمليه
السياسيه تحرك الطرفان الى ارض المشتركه
وهي ارض فيها كثير من الرمال المتحركه
اقصد قوى سياسيه همم لها وزنها المقدر
والمعتبر منهم شركاء في الثوره هو منهم
غير ذلك همم يقفون في محاربه قويه خلف هذا
الذي اتفاق الاطاري هذا الاتفاق في تقديري
هو الان يستجيب الى مطلوبات خارجي حسب
تصريحات مسؤولين عسكريين كبار
من قاعده الدعم السريع الذي صرح بصوره
واضحه انه ياتي السياره لتعاطي مع جهه
اجنبيه ولذلك هو في تقدير يستجيب الى
مطلوبات اجنبيه باكثر مما يستجيب الى
مطلوبات وطنيه همم تلبي طموحات الشعب
السوداني هذا الواقع المازوم لهذا الاتفاق
وهذا الميلاد المبتسر والمتعثر همم يوحي
ويحيى بانه لن يعمر طويلا وانه سيكون يضاع
الى فتره زمنيه قادمه محسوبه على معاده
الشعب السوداني الذي صبر كثيرا على ما
يمكن نسميه
حتى داخل المكون العسكري ليس هناك همم
اجماع على القيام بهذه الخطوه بشكلها
الحالي بهذا الاطار
ليس هذا المقصود انما تحدثت من المكون
العسكري نفسه استجاب لضغوط اجنبيه واستجاب
الى مطلوبات الالي الرباعيه والاليه
الثلاثيه وكثير من سفراء الدول الذين
يشكلون تكوين هذه الاليات
واستجاب الى مطلوبات هي ليست بالضروره
المطلوبات الشعب السوداني بالدرجه الاولى
استجابه للضغوط خارجيه والضطر الى ان يضع
يده في تحالف الثنائي طالما تحدث كثيرا عن
روضه له وانه لن يستجيب الى اي ضغوط او
همم مطلوبات الى وضع يده او التوقيع اتفاق
الثنائي يتخلى عن هذا الموقف وتقدم كثيرا
الى هذه الرمال المتحركه
ان يحاطه هذا هذا المؤتمر بكل هذه الاحاطه
الدوليه وكذلك الاقليميه الى اي مدى قد
يكون مفيد في ظل هذا الانقسام الحاصل حتى
الاطراف المعنيه المشاركه تشعر بانها قدمت
تنازل كما قال اللواء محمد اجيب بناءا او
استجابه او تعاملا مع نداءات خارجيه
وبالتالي ماذا عن البعد والتوافق الداخلي
في انجاح هذا المؤتمر وهذه خطوه ايا كان
الاطار الدولي الذي يحيط بها
اولا طبعا يعني انا بفتقر اتفاق الايطالي
التاكيد اول حاجه بتاع القوات المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع بانهم خارج نطاق
العمليه السياسيه وبالتالي هذا القوه
المدنيه لابد ان تلتقطه حتى تفرض نفسها
للتحول الديموغرافي
الكلام عن انه قوه خارجيه ومساء زيدي ده
كلام يعني هو بيقلل منك يا سودانيين احنا
في عالم مترابط عالم موجود
وكل الازمات العالميه يحصل فيها تدخل هنا
وهناك لكن ما اريد ان اقوله ليس للثلاثيه
ولا الرباعيه ولا القوه
الاجنبيه يد في هذا الاتفاق الايطالي والا
كان اذا كان جاء معلب ما كان يفتح
بناء على انه
استوعب كل الناس السودانيين كل القوه
المدنيه
شيء طبيعي ما يعني حكايه الكلام ده جاي من
الخارج
السودانيين السودانيين خبراء في كل حته
مسائل علوم رايه ولهم تجاربون وكذا
اقول انه
الحريه والتغيزات نفسها ليست ملك لهذا
الاتفاق الان اتفاق مفتوح في اكثر من كم و
انا اقول انه حتى خلافات
كامله نظام الفهد هو
الرغم السودان في كل المشاكل
حقيقه
مؤسسه العسكريه مؤسسه الشرطه
معين هذه الظروف الان في سبيل العلاقه طيب
تمام
السلطه حتى يتم توافق في الفتره
الانتقاليه وننتقل من مرحله التعيين
بمرحله
الدوليه الممثله الخاص الامين العام للامم
المتحده رئيس البعثه الاميه لدعم المرحله
الانتقاليه في السودان
دعى الاطراف السياسيه الرافضه الاتفاق
الايطالي الى المشاركه في العمليه
السياسيه الراهنه لانهاء الازمه ايضا قال
ان هناك اعتراضات على الاتفاق الايطالي
تتطلب الاستماع اليها ومناقشتها وشدد بيرث
على ان المجتمع الدولي سيلتزم بوعوده بشان
تقديم المساعدات اذا تم توصله الى حل
واتفاق سياسي وهنا اثر الدكتور صديق وفي
تتعلق بالمجتمع الدولي وهو متحد يقدم
نفسها كطرف ميسر لهذه
المشاورات وتطلب من يرفض المشاركه في هذه
المشاورات وهذا المؤتمر الى ان يشارك
ويكون جزء من من من اجل حل هذه الازمه لما
لا تتعاملنا ايجابيا مع هذه الدعوه
الدوليه
طبعا يعني ليس بالضروره ان ان يكون يعني
همم
اهتمام المجتمع الدولي بشان السوداني هو
يعني همم
انتقاص من من الذين يتعاملوا مع ال- عمليه
سوريه
الاتفاق الاطاري من القوه السودانيه من
قوه الثوره ان احنا يعني انا نفترض حسن
النيه في هذه القوه الوطنيه وانها تبحث عن
مخارج وكلنا سودانيين نبحث عن حل ازمه
حقيقيه همم يعيشها
شعبنا منذ سنوات ولكن همم يعني المجتمع
الدولي هو ليس ادرى بالتفاصيل نحن يعني
كشعب سوداني اهل مكه ادرى بشعارها الازمه
الحقيقيه ليست ازمه اشراك اي يعني من هبه
ودبه على يعني في شكلي لما اطراف وهكذا
وانما هناك ازمه سياسيه همم
همم نظام معين وما ضروره الفتره
الانتقاليه ان تهيا البلاد بتصحيح الاوضاع
المختله التي يعني هي تمثل تاريخه ذلك
النظام
الذي اسقطته الثوره السودانيه وبالتالي لا
يمكن همم
للقيام بمثل هذه المهمه الكبيره هذه
الركام والترك الكبير من من خراب الانقاذ
الثلاثين عام لا يمكن همم معالجتها بذات
همم بذات الادوات التي همم اوجدتها
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان تتم هذه العمليه
ببساطه باشتراك من كان جزء من الانقلاب
الانقاذ نفسه او الذين ساندوه حتى لحظه
سقوطه ومساله فتحه لكي حتى اعداء الثوره
والى اخره السمه الابرز بين مختلف الاطراف
بما فيها المشاركه في هذه المشاركه هذا
المؤتمر هي عدم الثقه اسال ضيفي اللواء
محمد عجيب فيما يتعلق كيف يمكن احداث
الثقه رغم هذه الوعود الدوليه وهذه المظله
الدوليه كيف يمكن احداث الثقه في ظل هذه
الاتهامات الجوهريه ومن ضمنها متطالم مكون
العسكري
لم اسمعك جيدا لو تكرمت بهذا السؤال سالتك
عن مساله عدم الثقه المطروحه الان حتى
يشارك الجميع في هذه المشاورات في ظلمه
مطروح فيها رغم المظله الدوليه الداعمه
كيف يمكن الوصول الى همم الثقه وكل هذه
الشقوق بما فيها ما يتعلق بما وعد به
المكون العسكري
واضح
اللواء محمد علي وعوده الى ضيفه السيد
كمال اسماعيل ايضا حول ذات النقطه مساله
عدم وجود الثقه بين الاطراف سواء التي
تشارك في هذا الحوار او المقاطعه لهذا
الحوار حتى لدى الشارع السوداني هناك من
يقول ما يجري الان ما هو الا تمديد بصوره
اخرى لواقع يعرفه السودانيون
حقيقه يعني المطلوب طبعا في ظل الظروف مثل
التي حدثت في بلادنا ان التوافق ده لا
يمكن ان يكون 100% لكن انا
موجود وشايف انه كل يوم في مجموعه من
الناس كان لجام مقاومه تنسيقات هي
هي عشان توقع في الاتفاق الايطالي الصيغه
بتدخلك في الهاتف في انه هذا الاتفاق
مفتاح وفي اتفاق نهائي وفي اعلان سياسي كل
القوه هتشترك فيهم نحن حريصون تماما على
انه هذا الاتفاق يتجمع حوله اكبر من القوه
المدنيه السودانيه لانه
لمسائل مهمه جدا جدا
هو ممثل امير العام المتحده جزء من الامم
المتحده جزء من الحركه الدوليه والجزء من
المجتمع الدولي لكن
كله ما تعمل انا واكد تماما انه هذه
المسائل اتعملت في
ايادي سودانيه دليل على ذلك البورشه بتاعت
المحامين
حينما قامت قبل الناس
داخل اول يوم هجموا مناسب المؤتمر الوطني
بالحجاره
نوايا مبيته
نحن مطالب كله شعبنا وكل احزاب من السوريه
سالته عن عدم الثقه التي تميز هذا الوضع
سواء حتى في داخل المشاركين في هذا مؤتمر
وجزء من عدم الثقه فيما يتعلق بما وعد به
المكون العسكري
اذا مازال هناك مشكله في الصوت اسال ضيف
الدكتور صديق تاور هناك من يراهن بان حتى
الاطراف التي لم تشارك في هذا المؤتمر سوف
تشارك في مرحله قادمه بينما بعض الاطراف
الرافده تقول باننا سوف ننزل للشارع
وبالتالي ما تصور المشهد
تصور التصور المشهد هو انه يعني الطرف
الاساسي الذي خلق الازمه يوميا يهزم في
هذا الاتفاق بسلوكه العمل الاتفاق واحده
من دهاناته همم سياسات او اجراءات ابداء
حسن النوايا ولكن عمليا منذ التوقيع هذا
الاتفاق الانتهاكات مستمره القمع مستمر
للاحتجاجات السلميه التعامل مع الاضرابات
والحقوقيه للمعلمين لموظفين الضرائب والى
اخره تتم
بالمضايقات
والنقل التعسفي والتحديد الاجراءات
الاداريه المعرقله
همم في خلال هذا الاسبوع لاحظت ثم احد
المصورين الاستاذ عثمان منصور الجزيره فقد
الكاميرا
السياده السوداني السابق وكذلك الشكر
موصول لضيف السيد كمال اسماعيل رئيس حزب
التحالف السوداني والقيادي بقوه الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي وكذلك كان معنا
اللواء محمد عجيب مدير مركز مدير الاعلام
العسكري
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]